economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela muy
buenas noches el fondo monetario
internacional mejoró sus proyecciones de
crecimiento mundial para este año una
mirada positiva claro que si santiago
buenas noches vídeo después de hundirse
un 3,5 por ciento en el 2020 la economía
mundial podría crecer un 5 5 por ciento
este año aunque cabe aclarar que este
aumento se genera es por una especie de
rebote no quiere decir que vamos a
volver pronto a los niveles pre
pandémicos pero si hablamos de américa
latina en particular que es la región
más afectada el organismo reveló que en
2020 la caída fue mayor que la del resto
del mundo fue del 7,4 por ciento
mientras que para este año espera una
recuperación un poco superior al 4% esta
proyección es mejor que la que tenía en
octubre aunque todo dependerá de las
vacunas
we news vaccination si tenemos mejores
noticias sobre vacunas y un lanzamiento
más rápido entonces las cosas podrían
mejorar más pero por otro lado si hay
mutaciones del virus que retrasan las
vacunas los nuevos resurgimientos pueden
tener un efecto negativo sobre la
actividad económica no también depende
mucho de que el apoyo político se
mantenga
daniela en la nueva jornada del foro
económico virtual de davos las
tecnológicas fueron las totales
protagonistas de la jornada o por lo
menos algunas aparte de las vacunas mire
una de las intervenciones de este martes
en la cumbre de líderes mundiales fue la
de la cancillera alemana angela merkel
quien insistió en que se necesita una
regulación global para gigantes
digitales como facebook google apple y
amazon esta es una idea que se estuvo
analizando en el seno de la ucedé pero
washington decidió retirarse de la
discusión bajo la administración de
donald trump escuchemos
debemos encontrar respuestas
multilaterales para los nuevos desafíos
de la digitalización y espero que ahora
con la nueva
un estadounidense podamos continuar e
intensificar los trabajos de la ocde
sobre la tributación mínima de las
empresas digitales para que así podamos
fijar mejor las leyes de la competencia
y evitar el surgimiento de monopolios
daniela hablemos de temas de la región
en argentina el gobierno anunció un
acuerdo sobre los precios de la carne a
un producto importantísimo para las
exportaciones argentinas
santiago el firmante del acuerdo es el
mayor consorcio exportador de carnes de
ese país que es el quinto productor
mundial y lo que busca es recuperar el
consumo doméstico que se ha visto
afectado por la pandemia del coronavirus
veamos según datos oficiales cada
argentino consumió en 2020 un total de
49 7 kilos de carne 12 kilos menos que
en 2019 y eso se debió a que los precios
se dispararon pues ahora prometen
reducir el precio de una decena de los
cortes que más se consumen entre un 15 y
un 30 por ciento incluyendo los de la
popular y deliciosa parrilla
participarán unos 2500 puntos de venta
que van a ofrecer unas 6000 toneladas
mensuales pero algunos gremios locales
han dicho que el acuerdo apenas incluye
una pequeña parte de todo lo que se
consume mensualmente en argentina además
que en este acuerdo participan las
grandes cadenas que muchas veces no son
de fácil acceso para gran parte de la
población hablamos ahora del super bowl
en eeuu daniela que se está quedando sin
algunos de sus anunciantes más
importantes pues algunos de ellos como
por ejemplo la gigante fabricante de
cerveza budweiser que lo hace por
primera vez en 37 años y otros como
cocacola hyundai o el mismo audi que
decidieron no emitir anuncios durante el
evento deportivo que tiene la publicidad
más costosa del mundo pepsico también
anunció que no hará publicidad a su
icónica bebida para centrarse en el
patrocinio del show de mitad de tiempo
que este año tendrá the weekend cocacola
dice que tomó la complicada decisión de
no pautar para dedicarse a sortear la
crisis
obligó a despedir a más de 2.000
personas en el pringoso toyota en cambio
si decidieron mantener este espacio y es
que santiago la tengo este dato mire la
cantidad de dinero en juego no es poca
el año pasado se pagaron más de 5
millones de dólares por cada 30 segundos
al aire son increíbles los precios
daniela muchas gracias por esta
actualización del mundo de la economía
está por el momento siga con nosotros
buenas noches
[Música]